експерти лондонського міжнародного
інституту стратегічних досягнень
проаналізували 37 із броні конфлікту
у святому жертва моєї ляльки наметі встав
і 167 тисяч людей знак моєї ж витрати на
у серії про конфлікт в Україні за канали
в жопу на 9000 осіп еміліч від 20 тисяч
пар вона але солодкий з державою то йєнн
іскру потужність гаранту вати б спайку
tower homo 100 права була поза завдяки
грози для України
якона сліду рамаяни шукати
альтернативні форми для своєї bespeco
зокрема у вас broen їх групах c засвоїти
аргус завдаючи заростання
праворадикальних росіян і держава не
можеш контролювати ці процеси місці
домового на стіни та працюйте на думку
лондонські експерти і багато становища
води будуть за підсумками їм цього їх на
можна було викинутим засіки цисту suite
конституційної реформи the power мене
україні контролю за російсько-українською
кордоном у будинку міжнародних
миротворчих до України повз essence
поважайте міжнародному інституті
стратегічних досліджів на першому
етапі ви ну може сховати ескалації
ситуації the same to малюка тим вартовий
ефект на думаю що він і фундаментальну
розв'язати конфлікт миротворцями севінч
україна показала ще виймає перший
успіх а на душі оголеної воронкова так
вже ви означало роботу моніторингової
місії б е
воду на проблему з посади величини маю
доступу на всю територію конфлікту
писанку лондонські експерти на душі
оптимістичніше диво покращення ситуації в
україні
кожухін та мою політичну волю
розв'язати конфлікт вин стою за морозивом
і з періодом з халату це
деескалації